[Música]
duas horas da manhã eu recebi um áudio
no meu celular eu estava acordada
trabalhando eu gosto muito de escrever e
contar tudo em silêncio só escutou um
barulho do meu teclado ouvir
imediatamente mas não é senão um áudio
recebido de madrugada pode ser um pedido
de socorro
podia se alguma mensagem que mudar os
rumos da minha vida era um pedido de
orçamento
não estou reclamando eu adoro o pedido
de orçamento nem vim pedir orçamentos
especificamente àquele pedido
o texto acordado o resto da madrugada e
eu confesso para vocês que também
modificou a maneira com que eu me
relaciono com o meu trabalho com as
pessoas
em determinado ponto do áudio áudio
longo é dizia eu quero a minha equipe
produzindo mais e mais quero uma equipe
funcionando como uma máquina e fiquei
pensando que será a funcionar como uma
máquina é aliás em que momento do mundo
a expressão funcionando como uma máquina
começou a ser utilizada como algo bom
com uma qualidade com uma vantagem um
aditivo
fiquei pensando sobre aquilo assim e
fiquei pensando em como a gente é
compartilhado por um tipo de informação
que se a gente parar bem pra pensar não
faz sentido nenhum venda como uma
máquina corra como uma máquina seu
intestino funcionando como uma máquina
pra quê porquê porque a gente precisa
funcionar com uma máquina
as máquinas são programadas para
obedecer as máquinas são insensíveis ao
contexto as máquinas praticamente não
erram
que graça tem não errar que tipo de
aprendizado se esconde na ausência da
falha
pra gente nenhum tem um poeta que chama
makovski e tem um trecho de um poema
dele
o que ele diz gente pra brilhar nesse
brilhar
eu interpreto de uma maneira bem livre
como existir sabendo que existir é
intervir de modo amoroso no mundo
isso pode ser feito de muitos jeitos o
que eu mais gosto e é por isso que eu
vim aqui conversar com vocês hoje é a
junção de palavras é a escrita é pegar
uma praia é pegar um texto e fazer com
que ele converse com uma outra pessoa
pra mim esse é um dos modos mais bonitos
de intervir modo amoroso no mundo
então sempre que alguém me procura é
pedindo um orçamento não às duas da
manhã a gente mas me procura para um
projeto de comunicação pra faz a gente
fazer alguma pra fazer aula para fazer
um projeto sobre narrativas estratégicas
storytelling nesse mundo de palavras que
hoje em dia a gente escuta por aí
a primeira coisa que eu peço é eu faço
um convite resgata a humanidade das suas
palavras
tira soberba da tom comunicação e começa
a escrever começa a produzir comunicação
para conversar com as pessoas
escreve para que as pessoas realmente
leiam para que elas passem os olhos e
esqueçam porque gente a quantidade de
informação que a gente tem todo dia
escreve para que as pessoas sintam se
desconheçam para que as pessoas sintam
muito para que as pessoas tenham novas
perguntas para que as pessoas que irão
ler mais para que as pessoas que irão
escrever também nesse momento talvez ele
esteja pensando aqui amor ela sabe até
falar maiakóvski mas o que ela falou até
agora não faz sentido nenhum pra mim e
talvez porque ele trabalha com
comunicação e nem trabalha com a palavra
talvez não faça sentido pra mim talvez
lá no fundo do coração tudo esteja
lembrando daquele grande pensador
contemporâneo tim maia me dê motivo não
vou te dar um motivo o motivo muito
especial
todas as pessoas que têm acesso
o privilégio
é ler e escrever é importante que a
gente lembre que é um privilégio e eu
espero tenho certeza que vocês esperam
que não seja um privilégio pra sempre
mas por enquanto ainda é todas as
pessoas que têm o privilégio por exemplo
enxergar as letras rsa x magicamente
enxergar a palavra rosa e saber que rosa
pode ser um nome de uma pessoa pode ser
um bom ou pode ser uma flor
todas essas pessoas que estão nesta sala
hoje que estão nessa cidade estão nesse
país que estão nesse planeta podem e
devem utilizar as palavras pra quebrar
muros de construir pontes
é isso que a gente precisa fazer a nossa
comunicação a nossa palavra o nosso
privilégio ele tem que ser utilizado
para que a gente utilize os textos para
conversar com as pessoas e aí pode
pensar mas eu ainda não entendi como é
que eu vou fazer isso eu não trabalho se
não é o meu trabalho se não no produto
do conteúdo o que quer que seja pode
começar por exemplo escrevendo na rede
social indicando o trabalho de alguém
também pode utilizar as palavras para
contar a história dos seus avós que há
duas ou mais gerações chegaram aqui em
situação de imigração exatamente como
hoje chegam pessoas em situação de
refúgio no brasil pode utilizar as
palavras para contar o que aconteceu
contigo o que aprendeu quando perdeu
tudo pode utilizar as palavras para
explicar o que que a empatia porque hoje
eu aprender o que a empatia
tu pode olhar o teu redor enxergar
situações que possam se transformar em
textos que possam inspirar outras
pessoas então não precisa de uma técnica
altamente rebuscada pra isso não precisa
saber os oito passos para um texto
perfeito importante que o saiba não
existem oito passos para o texto
perfeito porque nada é perfeito não
precisa ficar esperando a idéia perfeita
aconteceu um momento de alto pode chegar
em casa escreveu hoje quem sabe que pode
começar escrevendo um bilhetinho
bem pequeno para uma pessoa que está bem
pertinho e que talvez não saiba mais o
espaço imenso que ocupa dentro do teu
coração
utilizo ter o privilégio de ter acesso à
palavra escrita
escreve faz o que as máquinas são e
serão absolutamente incapazes escreve
para transformar as pessoas em luzes
acesas
é isso que a gente precisa no mundo a
gente precisa que as pessoas estejam
atentas curiosos com vontade de se
emocionar com vontade de saber mais
tem uma escritora que eu adoro que chama
rosa monteiro
ela tem um ensinamento que eu acho que
fala muito do que conversamos aqui agora
ela fala é a palavra que nos torna
humanos é juntando isso com o áudio que
eu recebi as duas a duas horas da manhã
e olhando aqui pra vocês eu fico
pensando que sorte nossa né
[Aplausos]